- What's been your favorite part
of making movies so far?
I imagine you are so fun
to work with, by the way.
- I liked to have fun for sure.
I like, you know, for sure
you gotta take work seriously
but I like to have fun while doing it.
So for sure, try and be
keep the jokes going and everything.
But I would say like my favorite things
about being in, working
on movies and stuff
so far is, I mean, two
things come to mind.
Is like the really dope people you meet
along the way that are like so different
that you didn't think you would have
crossed paths with before.
Super rad meeting new people.
And secondly, like right out of the oven,
fresh-baked chocolate chip cookies.
(laughing)
- Somehow I knew you were
headed towards munchies.
- Honestly, they're so good.
They're so good.
Catering is so dank on movies, I swear.